[Music]
your dog
[Music]
you know what's so funny as you say
you're cold but you're really warming
nice what is it
cold cold like a lump of coal did yeah
it's got the first question poor ear
cold cold what is it darn it darn it
Oh first question stop I'm sorry go who
is the better dad in real life
who's a very dad in real life well I
think we both aspire to be the best dads
that we possibly can be but yet we have
stumbling blocks that we have to
overcome sometimes and right we make
poor choices sometimes and sometimes we
make mistakes but sometimes I give you a
gold Rolex
yeah meet and greet hello I buy my
children a brand new toy every day
that's how good a dad I will look at
those eyes light up
oh you're not feeling Cory you have a
question how would dad say you two have
a bromance
what's up Oh
this time I got romantic like a mom and
dad relationship but we still love each
other
yeah when we don't smooch on the lips
but he smooches his dad and lips for a
long weird weird oh yeah dad that 100
nice job oh thanks um dad someone just
buy some day next question here we go
why does my mom fancy mark on my grandma
fancy world Oh
taste but your grandma was formerly a
Playboy model right oh my worst job was
being interviewed by you you just say
the word when they want to slap it on
their thigh Phoenix
no I need a better actor than you you
got the part the Baffler goes to cold
cold sorry it's that cold on it see you
honey
Oh cold be birds out children who is
your favorite
Wow
no you can't pick that yeah you can't
it's that's you know I'm gonna get in
trouble
that would be unfair all 17 of my
children I love them equally
why does mark up their arms and well oh
that's fake it's one of those pads but
yeah if you dress up as the rock for a
Halloween no address with them
well are we nobody know the book isn't
scary yes the book why you guys like